fox news has been regularly bringing on
a so-called invasion expert to give his
analysis of what's going on in the
russian invasion of ukraine and oops lo
and behold
it turns out that the guy
is a trump-appointed putin propagandist
this guy's name is douglas mcgregor
douglas mcgregor has appeared with
tucker carlson and all he's all over fox
news as a so as a so-called expert on
the invasion and it turns out he's one
of these sort of putin defenders who at
one point was actually appointed by
donald trump listen to this this is a
very good article from rolling stone
outlining the entire thing
which says
trump at one point
nominated considered mcgregor for a
number of different jobs ultimately
nominated him to be the u.s ambassador
to germany
ultimately the nomination didn't pan out
when cnn reported on mcgregor's history
of racism trump was undeterred
appointing mcgregor as a pentagon's
senior adviser shortly after the 2020
election this guy is a bonkers pro-putin
guy okay let's look at some clips here
he is arguing against sanctions
basically saying the sanctions are
futile it's not gonna hurt it's not
gonna hurt putin it's not gonna hurt
russia it's the sanctions as you rightly
point out will do a lot of damage to us
they're not gonna make much difference
to russia china will stand with russia
it knows it has to russia has an
abundance of food and energy
china will take it all now everything he
said there is wrong
he's the guy's just wrong number one
although initially russia said we don't
care about the sanctions they're not
doing anything to us
russia later conceded actually the
sanctions are very damaging and painful
and it even led to putin
uh putting nuclear uh
uh elements of nuclear deterrence on
higher alert so
it was wrong that russia would not be
impacted by the sanctions and then
number two this idea that china will
never ever ever do anything anything
anything against russia in the last 24
hours china has started for the first
time uh referring to what russia has
done in ukraine as an invasion and as a
war and this is not something that they
previously had done so even on that he
is wrong as well next clip mcgregor went
on fox news this time with stuart varney
and said the russian army is actually
it's been too gentle
but now it's going to get everything
done within 10 days
he called zolensky a delusional puppet
and he said that all of the ukrainian
claims about what's going on are
propaganda wow
all of that is also false the
first five days
russian forces i think frankly were too
gentle
they've now corrected that so i would
say another 10 days this should be
completely over but the question is
uh what is it that zielinski is going to
do the russians have made it very clear
what they want is a neutral ukraine
this could have ended days ago if he
accepted that
and then they could guys if only
zielenski accepted the invasion this
would have ended a long time ago just
the borders but the eastern part of
ukraine is firmly in russian hands by
the way when he says adjust the borders
he's saying allow russia to steal the
land
but again the russians are not seizing
territory they're destroying ukrainian
forces that's their focus colonel it
sounds like you don't approve of
zelensky's stand
well i think zielinski is a puppet
uh and he is putting huge numbers of his
own population at unnecessary risk
and uh quite frankly most of what comes
out of ukraine is debunked as lies
within 24 to 48 hours that's also
completely untrue and uh once again
um
he said that it was only going to be 10
more days he said this back on march 4th
or 5th which means within five or six
days
according to this expert on invasions
russia should have taken ukraine my
prediction is that will not have
happened five to six days from now and
then lastly here he is saying uh we
gotta stop demonizing putin come on do
not want to do in our usual effort to
demonize him and his country we need to
remember that ukraine is fourth from the
bottom of 158 countries in the world
as corrupt russia is perhaps three or
four places above them this is not the
liberal democracy now i don't know what
he's citing there but as many of you
know
in multiple serious democracy indices
ukraine ranks much higher in democracy
than russia
shining example that everyone says it is
far from it mr zielenski has jailed
journalists and his political opposition
i think we need to stay out of it the
american people think we should stay out
of it the europeans think we should stay
out of it now that's also not true the
american people although they're they
don't want to commit troops and i agree
with that uh the american people think
we should be arming and supporting
ukraine i mean you can you can say that
that's wrong
but what mcgregor is saying is just
completely incorrect
he is the wrongest man you know how alex
berenson is the wrongest man in america
on covid
mcgregor seems to be the wrongest man in
america on russia ukraine and fox
continues bringing him on as an expert
when he's really just a putin
propagandist who couldn't even get the
position trump uh selected him for
because of his outrageous racist past
that came out we'll have these clips
that i played on our instagram at david
pakman's show if you want to check them
out
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below